in the last video we figured out the
mean variance and standard deviation for
a Bernoulli distribution with specific
numbers what I want to do in this video
is to generalize it to figure out really
the formulas for the mean and the
variance of a Bernoulli distribution if
we don't have the actual numbers if we
just know that the probability of
success is P and the probability of
failure is 1 minus P so let's look at
the let's look at this let's look at a
population let's look at a population
where the probability of success I will
define success as 1 as having a
probability of P of having a probability
of P and the probability of failure the
probability of failure has is 1 minus P
whatever this might be 1 minus P and
obviously if you add these two up if you
view them as percentages these are going
to add up to 100% or if you add up these
two values we're going to add to 1 and
that needs to be the case because every
a these are the only two possibilities
that can occur if this is if this is 60%
chance of success there should be a 40%
chance of failure 70% chance of success
30% chance of failure now with this
definition of this and this is the most
general this is the most general
definition of a Bernoulli distribution
of a Bernoulli distribution it's really
exactly what we did in the last video I
now want to calculate the expected value
which is the same thing as the mean of
this distribution and I also want to
calculate I also want to calculate the
variance which is the same thing as the
expected squared distance of a value
from the mean so let's do that so what
is what is the mean over here what is
going to be the mean well that's just
the probability weighted sum of the
values that this can take on so there is
a 1 minus P probability there is a 1
minus P probability that we get failure
that we get zero so there's 1 1 minus P
probability of getting is 0 of getting 0
2 times you
and then there is a P probability a P
probability of getting one plus P times
one plus P times one well this is pretty
easy to calculate zero times anything is
zero so that cancels out and then P
times one is just going to be P is just
going to be P so pretty straight forward
the mean the expected value of this
distribution is P and P might be you
know here or something so it's once
again it's a value that you cannot
actually take on in this distribution
which is interesting but it is the
expected value now what is going to be
the variance what is the variance of
this distribution the variance remember
that is the weighted sum of the squared
distances from the mean now what's the
probability that we get a 0 we already
figure that out there's 1 minus P
probability that we get a 0 so that is
the probability part and what is the
squared distance from 0 to our mean well
the squared distance from 0 to our me
let me write it over here
it's going to be 0 that's the value
we're taking on let me do that in blue
since I already wrote 0 and 0 minus our
mean minus our - let me do this in a new
color
- our mean that looks that's too similar
to that orange let me do the mean and
white zero minus our mean which is P
which is P plus the probability that we
get a 1 which is just P plus the
probability we get a 1 just P and this
is this is the squared distance let me
be very careful it's the probability
weighted sum of the squared distances
from the mean now what's the distance
now we got a 1 and what's the discrete
one on the mean it's 1 minus our mean
which is going to be which is going to
be P over here and we're going to want
to square this we want to square this as
well this right here is going to be the
variance now let's actually work this
out so this is going to be equal to 1
minus P now 0 minus P is going to be
negative P if you square it you're going
to get P squared so it's going to be P
squared then plus
plus P times what's 1 minus P squared 1
minus P squared is going to be 1 squared
it's going to be 1 squared which is just
1 minus 2 times the product of this so
it's going to be minus 2p right over
here minus 2p and then plus negative P
squared so plus P plus P squared just
like that and now let's multiply let's
multiply everything out let's multiply
everything out this is going to be this
term right over here it's going to be P
squared minus P to the third and then
this term over here this whole thing
over here is going to be plus P times 1
is P P times negative 2 P is negative 2
P squared and then P times P squared is
P to the third now we can simplify these
P to the third cancels that with P to
the third and then we have P squared
minus 2 P squared so this right here
becomes you have this P right over here
so this is equal to P and then when you
add P squared to negative two P squared
you're left with negative P squared so
net minus P squared and if you want to
factor a P out of this this is going to
be equal to P times if you take P
divided by P you get a 1 P squared
divided by P is P so P times 1 minus P
which is a pretty neat clean formula so
our variance is P times 1 minus P and if
we want to take it to the next level if
we want to take it to the next level and
figure out the standard deviation the
standard deviation is just the square
root is just the square root of the
variance which is equal to the square
root of P x times 1 minus P and we can
even verify that this actually works for
the example that we did up here our mean
is P the probability of success we see
that indeed was it was 0.6 and we know
that our variance is essentially the
probability of success times the
probability of failure that's our
variance right over there probability of
success in this example was 0.4 or
probability of success was
six probability of failure is 0.4 you
multiply the two you get point two four
which is exactly what we got in the last
example and if you take its square root
for the standard deviation which is what
we do right here it's 0.49 so hopefully
you found that helpful and we're going
to you were going to build on this later
on in some of our inferential statistics